welcome to the monitor as always Peter
Rubin senior editor at Wired back alive
and in one piece from 2012 san diego
comic-con international where I did my
best to run our entire video team into
the ground so huge house to them for for
keeping up and turning out so many great
videos which I'm sure you've been
watching all week this week on the
monitor instead of doing three different
releases for the week I'm actually gonna
run down my 10 favorite things that I
saw comic-con this year so let's kick
this off with number 10 Marvel unveiling
their next phase of movie domination
after the Avengers we knew that they had
stuff on tap we knew there was going to
be a sequel to captain america and thor
and obviously Iron Man 3 and we brought
you the first look at that suit over the
weekend but marvel at their press
conference officially unveiled titles
and release dates for all those movies
plus guardians of the galaxy which will
be coming out in 2014 number 9 the
majestic files J michael Straczynski
upcoming comic series in which he
retells / reimagines the roswell UFO
crash of 1947 looks like it's going to
be really good even if you're tired of
that kind of story number 8 the
community panel not the panel of the
comic-con community but the show
community season 4 stars October and the
new showrunners replacing Dan Harmon and
the show's cast packed into ballroom 20
and actually showed us this incredible
gag reel that's going to be on the
upcoming season three DVD number seven
the incredible prints made by mondo
which is the boutique art collective
that is affiliated with alamo drafthouse
theater in Austin they brought posters
for sale to the show floor that included
Game of Thrones Creature from the Black
Lagoon mimic and a host of others people
were snapping them up the limited runs
were really really popular and were
beautiful to boot number six Rian
Johnson's time travel sci-fi film
loopers coming out in late-september I
personally have been lucky enough to see
it but a lot of people at comic-con
packed into the panel to see new footage
that they hadn't already seen in the
trailer as you may or may not know this
is Joseph gordon-levitt as
hitman in the future who has to come
face to face with his even more future
self played by Bruce Willis it's an
incredible imaginative original sci-fi
movie and I really hope that this picks
up the steam that it deserves number 5
oz the great and powerful director and
legend Sam Raimi is back with this
prequel to this story that you may or
may not know called The Wizard of Oz
with James Franco as the would-be wizard
he is still just an inventor who takes
off on a hot air balloon finds himself
in a magical land full of a special
effects budget that mere mortals cannot
even comprehend number four Neil Gaiman
is back for more sandman in a surprise
video announcement the writer announced
that he would be returning for the 25th
anniversary of the original 1988 launch
of the incredible comic series with a
new series while a new miniseries rather
that examines where Morpheus was before
the start of the series and how he got
to where the series finds him at its
opening with art by JH williams a third
they also released one little teaser
image that we're showing you right here
and i as well as comic fans couldn't be
more excited number three django
unchained has a new sizzle reel Quentin
Tarantino meets up with kristoff vaults
from inglorious basterds Jamie Foxx
Kerry Washington Leo DiCaprio and a host
of other people for a I'm just going to
call it a darkly comic tale of a freed
slave who becomes a bounty hunter in
civil war-era south it is super violent
and super funny judging from the new
footage that fans got to see at the Hall
H panel this year number two pacific rim
and Elysium yes these are two different
movies and they would get their own and
they might both be tied for number one
if there was video to show you but
Pacific Rim which is Guillermo del
Toro's upcoming kaiju robot versus alien
warfare spectacular and Elysium which is
district nine writer director Neill
Blomkamp's return and his new space
sci-fi with Matt Damon and Jodie Foster
they both had panels they both showed
footage for the first time neither of
which had footage that
we have to show you but trust me when I
say that each had a few minutes of
footage that had fans going absolutely
berserk and both are two of the most
anticipated titles of next year but for
number one we have something that we
don't have to wait until next year to
see and that is Peter Jackson returning
with the wizards at wetta for the hobbit
an unexpected journey the first of his
two part adaptation of The Hobbit which
of course is the prequel or the prelude
to the Lord of the Rings trilogy this is
Martin Freeman as Bilbo Baggins and
brings back Gandalf and a whole new host
of dwarves or whole old host of doors
since you will know them as the
predecessors to Gimli and the rest from
Lord of the Rings but this is the story
of how Bilbo met Gollum went on a crazy
journey and found a certain ring that
may propel the rest of the series and
that's that a lot of stuff we saw this
year not a lot of sleep we got this year
but that's okay because we're doing it
for you so until next week when we're
back with more actual current releases
email us at the monitor at wired.com and
until then inspirational catchphrase
here
you